my name's samuel leeds and i wanted to
show you i mean listen i'm going to show
you how i find land
when i'm buying land or at least how not
to look for land
because people often approach me with
pieces of land
and land can look really attractive you
know
when agents come to you and they show
you their drawings
um so i wanted to just give you an
example of what that can look like
and how you got to be really careful as
well so
all right let's let's do this so here we
go piece of land for sale
guide price 250 000 pounds i remember
when i saw this when it first came on
and people were sending it to me saying
oh look this could be a great little
piece of land
could be a good project it's really
close to my house
um and and look look
oh unsold in auction is that a good
thing or a bad thing
i mean how do you know if it's a good
thing or a bad thing it's coming back on
now it's about to go to auction
and it's less than half the price so 100
grand
about to go to auction next week for a
piece of land
where you can build that on it i mean
geez
what's gonna what's going to be the
return on investment
let me have a look at the pictures so
looks fabulous so this is just um a 3d
a 3d image of what it would look like
when it's built
that's the piece of land um
so you'll read through and you'll be
interested it says it's on
0.96 of an acre that's almost an acre
okay um development scheme preparing
full vacant possession
now listen this hasn't got planning so
you need to get planning
but looking at this you think okay well
that's good
because the money is in the planning the
money's in the planning
so i'll buy the piece of land and then
i'll get planning
push the value right up build this thing
and then the end value is going to be
really high that's how you make money
right
well let's have a look exactly where
this where this is
so this is right next to the station
next to sear green and jordan's station
which is a really affluent area
so the land is somewhere around here so
um
if we just type in see a green
station
let's see if we can find this bad boy
okay it looks like this is the land
site area 0.96 acres so that's the land
now the way that it's packaged up looks
great
because you can see the 3d images isn't
it wonderful
but actually when you look into this
site
and this is what this is what what
people and this is why i think training
is so important
because someone could literally go ahead
and just buy that piece of land in faith
that they'd get planning
um let's see if you get planning well
for a start where's the access gonna be
if you have an apartment block here okay
how are you gonna get to the apartment
block well the access is i mean
you're not going to be able to put a
road through here
unless you get the permission from like
it's just not really going to happen
maybe through here it's going to have to
be
but what is this well
this is a parking this is the this the
parking
the car park for the station so
actually unless you're gonna access this
on a helicopter
there's no access so you're going to buy
this little piece of land
but then you're going to ask the council
for planning permission
and they're going to simply say a big
fat
steamy no why because there's no access
i mean you you're not really going to
get permission from
to be able to use this as an access like
how is this going to happen
another thing is if you click if we
click on it again
and we read the re read what's what
environmental it's 100
green belt so this is green belt land
with no access so you're not going to
get planning on it
so what's going to happen were you going
to buy it you're going to spend 100
grand on it
to be able to do absolutely nothing with
it potentially could be a waste of 100
grand
just because you got suckered in by the
nice
idea of building on it
i mean the best way if you want to know
about planning the best way to know if
you're going to get planning or not as
well
is to see is it going to be fitting to
the area
i mean imagine you just build a sudden
apartment block here
there's nothing like it elsewhere it
would be very random and
unfitting the council are going to say
no on so many accounts
i mean geez i wonder if these trees are
even protected trees they might be
it's just not happening but the estate
agents don't care about that
the estate agents listen i'm not
knocking the estate agent at all
but the the seller the person that's
selling the land i imagine
i imagine can't get planning knows
they won't be able to get planning so
it's just packaging it up selling it to
some dum dum
tried to sell it for 250 but it failed
now selling it again for 100 grand
and it will probably it will either fail
to sell or some dum-dum will buy it
i mean unless you're buying it just to
land bank it um
but you can see look if we get the
little man it looks so
pretty it looks so pretty on here
this looks so wonderful and beautiful
but when you zoom in and you see what it
actually looks like on google earth
this is what you're buying
this is it no access
a bunch of trees where you're not going
to get planning to build at
anything at all absolutely pointless
unless you're just trying to build your
bank of land
so what's the lesson in this the lesson
is don't get suckered in
by 3d pictures
that doesn't mean there's planning
permission to go ahead and do it
get properly educated get good
architects
planning consultants get a good power
team um
and don't waste a hundred thousand
pounds if you enjoy my channel do me a
massive favor smash like
subscribe i'll do plenty more videos
like this real soon peace